CHRIS WILSON: Good afternoon
and welcome to Turning
the Web Up to 11.
I'm Chris Wilson.
I'm a Developer Advocate
on the Chrome team.
And I'm here to take you
on a journey through
the Web Audio API.
So if you didn't know what
I was going to talk
about, now you do.
I wanted to start by showing why
I'm so excited about the
Web Audio API.
When I first ran across the Web
Audio work, I got really
excited because for the last
couple years, I've gotten
really interested in building
and using software
synthesizers, drum machines, all
kinds of production stuff,
on desktop and also
on tablets.
And I'd gotten really
excited about this.
I wanted to start
building my own.
And as I looked at the Web Audio
API, it looked super
easy to do, super interesting.
And I actually very quickly
realized that most of building
a software synthesizer with
web audio ends up being a
really big user interface
chore.
And I'm not a great
UI designer.
You'll probably notice
that during my deck.
So I set my sights on a
different challenge.
Because I wanted to do something
that was really
pretty heavy duty with
audio processing.
So I decided I would set my
sights on making robot voices.
Or more particularly, building
a vocoder and trying to
replicate Styx's seminal
1983 hit "Mr. Roboto."
And I'm actually happy
to report that I've
managed to do this.
This is actually a vocoder
that I built.
It's up on GitHub right now.
There's a link to it at
the end of the deck.
So you can go play with it
yourself, or fork it and do
all kinds of interesting
things with it.
So how many people know what a
vocoder is or how it works?
Yeah, the guy on the Web Audio
team doesn't actually get to
raise his hand.
But I kind of figured.
So I don't want to get
really deeply to
vocoder theory or anything.
Basically, what a vocoder does
is it takes one signal,
generally called the modulator,
it's usually a
vocal sample.
Something like this--
PLAYBACK: Four score and seven
years ago, our fathers brought
forth on this continent.
CHRIS WILSON: And it maps the
frequency characteristics of
that sound over time.
It chops it up into
frequency bands.
And then it watches how
much energy is in
each frequency band.
And it maps it onto a different
signal, the carrier
signal, which is usually
a synthesized sound.
Something like this--
[BUZZING NOISE]
CHRIS WILSON: And I had
to tell the audio guys
beforehand, No, that's not
something going wrong.
That is actually what
it's supposed to
sound like right now.
It sounds really awful, right?
But when you actually map the
frequency characteristics onto
that sound, it ends up sounding
kind of like this--
PLAYBACK: [ROBOT VOICE]
Four score and seven years ago,
our fathers brought forth
on this continent.
[CONTINUES PLAYING
IN BACKGROUND]
CHRIS WILSON: It's
kind of cool.
It's actually somewhat
recognizable.
Now the interesting thing about
this code, to me after
having written it, is that this
is not being precomputed.
This is actually
happening live.
In fact, I can change
characteristics.
Like I can detune the
voices being used.
[VOICE SPEEDS UP]
CHRIS WILSON: And change
how it sounds.
[VOICE SLOWS DOWN]
CHRIS WILSON: Or I can also
change what voices are being
used to produce it.
So if I grab and--
[VOICE DEEPENS]
CHRIS WILSON: I'm probably using
a different sample or
something like that.
So I have a lot of control
over what's going on.
In fact, the only bit of my
JavaScript code that's running
while this is going, is the
stuff used to animate the
vocoder bands, how the frequency
bands are jumping
around, and the input
and output signals.
So the ability to build rich
audio applications like this.
Because by the way, I'm
not an audio engineer.
I'm not a digital signal
processing expert or anything.
It did take me a lot of trial
and error to build this.
But the ability to build rich
audio apps like this, without
having a degree in audio
engineering, is why I'm so
excited about the processing
capabilities here.
And I will stop that.
Because you can go play
with it yourself.
Oops.
Click on my slides here.
So you might start out by
asking, why do we even need
another API?
We already have the HTML5
audio element.
And I love the HTML5
Because it wraps everything
about audio--
loading, decoding, and playing
audio-- all up into one easy,
declarative step.
Right?
You stick an audio tag in.
You tell it whether you want to
show the controls or not,
whether you want to pre-load
it, give it the source, and
you're good to go.
Like I can--
gonna turn my sound down
just a little here.
I click the button.
[LASER SOUND]
CHRIS WILSON: I probably
can turn it back up.
[LASER SOUND]
CHRIS WILSON: Click
the button.
And it plays the sound.
In fact, I even get built-in
scrubbing of the sound.
So I can--
if I stop hitting my
right button--
[PLAYS END OF LASER SOUND]
CHRIS WILSON: I can scrub
it to part of the
sound and hit play.
Now this is great.
But the thing that you don't
get from the HTML5 audio
element is you don't get
sample-accurate control over
when the sound is going
to be played.
And it really struggles with
scalability, when you have a
whole bunch of sounds what you
want to play all at the same
time or very close
to each other.
It's kind of a challenge to
get it to scale to that.
Now the Web Audio API is
designed a little bit
differently.
It's really designed around
this idea of having very
precise timing of
lots of sounds.
So I can play the same
sound sample.
[LASER SOUND]
CHRIS WILSON: But I can also
play it a lot of times.
[MULTIPLE SIMULTANEOUS
LASER SOUNDS]
CHRIS WILSON: And it's very
precise in timing as to when
it's playing, exactly when
I hit the button.
The Web Audio API also provides
a really rich audio
pipeline for building effects
and filters and routing audio
around in different
powerful ways.
So adding an effect
to that same sound
file is really easy.
[LASER SOUND ECHOING]
CHRIS WILSON: And then finally,
the Web Audio API
builds in a bunch of hooks
so you can analyze, and
visualize, and kind of
manipulate the data on the
fly, as well.
So it's really pretty easy
to build something like--
[MUSIC PLAYING WITH
VISUAL ANALYZER]
CHRIS WILSON: A visual
analyzer.
I actually built this
visual analyzer
special for this talk.
And it didn't take very long.
We're going to walk through the
code a little bit later.
So looking at the API from the
top down, it's kind of
surprising that it's actually
designed to be a relatively
high-level API.
It's really pretty easy to do
basic tasks in the API, like--
PLAYBACK: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: Playing a sound.
That's the code for
it right there.
That's all that I needed to
do to play that sound.
Because I'd already had the
buffer loaded and we'll talk
about that.
But even better than that, the
effects and filters engine
doesn't require you to
be a DSP engineer.
If you told me that in order to
build that vocoder I had to
go build my own FFT algorithm
implementation, and come up
with a bunch of matrices
and transforms, and
stick it all together.
I would have walked away and
done something else, frankly.
Math is not my favorite thing
to do on a sunny afternoon.
So I probably would have figured
out something else.
But if you want to do that, if
you want to get right down
into the guts and do your own
processing in JavaScript, on
the fly, you absolutely
can do that with the
Web Audio API, too.
But most of the effects engine,
and certainly the
routing engine that we provide
in the implementation, it uses
a separate high-priority
thread.
It uses native implementation of
FFTs and things like that.
And that way we can resist
problems like glitching.
So if you have an application
that has pretty rich visuals
and nice animation, here.
[PLAYS POOL GAME]
CHRIS WILSON: I never sink
anywhere when I do this.
But this actually has
really rich sound.
It's in 3D.
So you actually hear the balls
clicking together in the
appropriate place
and everything.
It works better with headphones
obviously than in the room.
But you could tell
the sound wasn't
interfering with the audio.
And the audio wasn't interfering
with the sound.
And this is really critical,
to not have these things
interact with each other
accidentally.
Now when you look at what you
need to build gaming.
Because there are really two
major scenarios that we're
super interested in--
music applications and gaming.
Gaming has a lot of features
that are expected for high-end
console games.
You expect to see things like
I talked before about very
precise timing of audio
elements and
simultaneous sounds.
But you also expect to be able
to do things like position
sound in 3D, have automatic
effects happen, like Doppler
shift when the siren races past
you and the pitch seems
to change because of
the physics of it.
You also want to be able to do
things like filtering effects.
So that, if you're doing a
live chat, you want it to
sound like it's coming over the
radio or over a telephone.
So I can take that same
sample I did earlier--
PLAYBACK: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: And filter it so
it sounds like it's coming
over a really kind of
crappy-quality telephone.
And, of course, replicating
acoustic environments.
Like if you fire your BFG 9,000
in a huge hall, you
expect it to sound a little
different than if you fire it
in a small room.
And, of course, you need the
ability to create rhythms and
sequences and things
like that.
But also do automation.
Do automated fade ins, fade
outs, that sort of thing.
On top of that, for music
applications you also need to
be able to generate sound.
You need oscillators.
You need things like dynamics
processing, and distortion,
and things like that.
And, of course, this is where
frequency and waveform
analysis gets really
interesting.
So I want to start diving in
to how we make this happen
with the Web Audio API.
This is an application
that I wrote.
I'm going to use this multiple
times during the talk.
It's also posted on GitHub.
It's also posted publicly.
So you can just go run it.
It basically is something that
I built to let me kind of
explore, visually, the
Web Audio API.
So the first thing to understand
is that the Web
Audio API works on the concept
of a node graph.
You create nodes.
So I just created an audio
buffer source node.
And you connect them.
And in this case I'm going to
connect it to the speakers.
Because you need to connect
everything to the speakers if
you want to hear a sound.
And I'll hit play.
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: Yay.
So you get the basic idea.
Create nodes, connect them
together, hit play.
Now these node graphs can
be varying complexity.
What I just had here, that just
went away, was actually
really simple.
It just had two nodes--
the source code and the speaker
destination node that I played.
This is a little bit more
complex node graph.
But if you work through it one
piece at a time, it's pretty
straightforward.
There's a few sources.
There's a few effects.
They're mixed together in
sub-mixes and then it goes
through a compressor
and gets played.
That vocoder app that I ran in
the beginning, by the way, is
a really complex node graph.
It has somewhere around 420
nodes, I think, active while
it's playing, the whole time.
So you can tell how
scalable it is.
Because that's running on my
two-year-old MacBook Pro.
And really doesn't make the
system sweat even that much.
For a while I was accidentally
running two copies at the same
time, I was wondering why I
got a weird effect, but--
So I want to start by walking
through how to build all of
this audio code.
I'm not going to dig into the
code of the vocoder app.
I started trying to do that and
realized it's kind of hard
to explain in an hour.
But, at the same time, I do want
to walk through each of
these building blocks
and help you
understand how to use them.
Now you're going to have
to bear with me.
We have to get through five
types before I can start
playing with the fun stuff.
The first of those is
the AudioContext.
The AudioContext is kind of the
root of all things audio.
This is kind of similar to
a 2D canvas context.
So you create one of these.
And this is where you
get access to all
the other fun stuff.
First and foremost, of course,
this is where you get access
to the speakers.
And you have to route
everything to this
destination, to the speakers,
in order to
have it make sound.
Otherwise you're not plugging
the cable into
anything, in effect.
But we also have methods here
to create audio buffers, to
decode audio buffers from common
file formats like mp3,
or wav, or ogg, or that
sort of thing.
And this is also down at the
bottom where we create all
kinds of different
audio nodes.
And we're going to walk through
each one of those
audio nodes.
This is a good time to mention,
by the way, I show
you a lot of interfaces
in this talk.
These are not the precise
interface declarations.
I tried to simplify them to
make them a little more
understandable.
And, obviously, like I've
cropped a bunch the audio
nodes out of the bottom here.
So look in the spec
if you want the
full, complete version.
So this is the first line of Web
Audio applications, or a
very early line, I should say.
You need to create a
new AudioContext.
Right now, obviously, we're a
WebKit prefix, vendor prefix.
Sooner or later, that will go
away as we move the spec
through the standards process.
Now the second type
is AudioNode.
And I already said Web Audio API
is based on the concept of
a node graph.
AudioNode is basically the super
class for all nodes in
that graph.
In fact, it really only has
two things that are super
interesting.
It has a connect.
It has a disconnect.
You want to connect a source
node to a destination node,
you just call source.connect
and pass it the destination
you want to connect it to.
I will point out, here, there's
a second connect
method that takes
an AudioParam.
I don't want to get into the
implications of that, yet.
But I did want to call it out.
Because it's going to be
important later on.
And that leads me to the third
type, which is AudioParam.
The AudioParam is a really
kind of complex type to
understand at first.
But it ends up being super,
super important.
So most of the values, the
things you would think of as
values in the Web Audio API,
like the volume on a
gain-controlling node,
for example.
They're actually represented
as AudioParams.
Now you can still get and set
the values, the first thing in
the interface declaration.
You can go in and grab the
value out of there.
You can manipulate
it, set it to
something different, whatever.
And that's an easy
way to use it.
And I do use it that
way a lot.
But at the same time you
can also do things
that schedule it.
So you can say, I want to set
the value at a particular time
in the future.
Or, my personal favorite, I want
to ramp this over time.
I want to set the value to zero
now, but I want to ramp
it up to one over the course
of the next couple seconds.
And we handle that for you
under the covers in
the Web Audio API.
So you get really, really
smooth automation.
Because of course we can
do that very fast.
And I will show several examples
of how to do that.
So we covered the three
infrastructure bits of
context, nodes, and params.
Now I want to talk
about sounds.
And AudioBuffer is the
first thing to talk
about, audio buffers.
It represents a decoded
buffer of sound.
So that means it's actually
in memory.
And the bits are right there,
lined up in a row for you.
You can actually access them
in here as a float32array.
You can go directly twiddle,
get, set, whatever you want to
do with those bits.
You can, of course, also see the
sample rate and how long
the buffer is and that sort
of thing, if you want.
But if you want to, you can
access the data directly.
In fact, this set of code
creates an audio buffer and
gets the data, gets a pointer
to the data, and then just
sets it to random numbers.
This sounds like a goofy
thing to do, but
actually this is how--
[STATIC]
CHRIS WILSON: This is how
you get white noise.
You know, white noise is
actually musically useful in a
number of cases.
Like the vocoder app uses white
noise in one place.
So it's something that
you may want to do.
Now, of course, you typically
aren't really going to want to
directly set these values.
You're going to want to load
them from somewhere.
So usually, you'll do
something like this.
This is using pretty standard
XMLHttpRequest code.
I set up a new XHR request.
I open it with a get.
I point it to an mp3
file, in this case.
The only interesting bits here
are I set the response type to
arraybuffer.
Because I want to get this back
as an array, not as a
bunch of plain text.
It's an audio file.
It's probably not--
plain text is not going to
be super interesting.
And then when it loads, I
call the AudioContext's
decodeAudioData method.
And I give it that buffer that
I just got back from XHR.
And when it asynchronously
completes, it passes me back a
buffer, an audio buffer,
that I can then do
whatever I want with.
Now what, you might ask, do
I do with an audio buffer?
It's not a node, you might
notice if you go back to the
interface that we had
a minute ago.
It doesn't derive from node.
It's an object in
its own right.
So what you do is you use an
AudioBufferSourceNode.
An AudioBufferSourceNode is a
node that we wrap around--
or actually, we point
to an audio buffer.
And it's really important to
understand this is a one shot
playback node.
AudioBufferSourceNode can
only be played once.
This is really, really super
important, which is why I say
it multiple times during
this slide.
Once you've played the
AudioBufferSourceNode once,
you have to throw it away.
You don't have to throw
away the buffer.
The buffer you can keep
around and use as many
times as you want.
In fact, you can share
it with multiple
AudioBufferSourceNodes Buffer
Source that are
playing at the same time.
When I hit the fire button
repeatedly earlier, I only had
one copy of that sound buffer.
I just had multiple buffer
source nodes that pointed to
it and were playing
at the same time.
So buffer source node, the type
points to the buffer that
it's playing.
It also lets you change
the playback rate.
So you can make it playback
faster or slower.
Meaning you can increase
or decrease the pitch.
You can loop it.
You can tell it when
to start playing.
And you can tell when
to stop playing.
So let's look at how we use
these two together.
So the top part of this code
sample is the code you just
saw to do an XMLHttpRequest,
get the data back, call the
code audio data, and
get a buffer.
And the only difference is once
I've gotten the buffer, I
call this method bark().
And bark() creates a buffer
source node, points the buffer
for the buffer source node to
what we just loaded, connects
it to the speaker--
because remember, we have to
connect everything to the
speakers or we don't
hear anything--
and then calls noteOn
to start it.
And I can--
[BARK]
CHRIS WILSON: --make it bark.
There's "Hello, World,"
right there.
"Hello, dog," I don't
know, whatever.
Now if this were my
dog, on the other
hand, it would be loop.
Because she barks--
[REPEATED BARKING]
CHRIS WILSON: A lot.
I didn't actually want to
run this for 10 minutes.
But she does back about that
long, most of the time.
Now, there are a couple things
that I want to point out here.
One thing that I should have
mentioned before, when I was
talking about writing values
in, is the sound values are
actually floating-point
numbers.
It's negative one to one is
the range that we have.
But it's floating point.
It's not 16-bit integers, it's
not 24-bit integers, or 32-bit
integers, which if you were
heavy into digital sound in
the past, you might
have expected.
The reason is that gives us
a lot of play in where the
dynamic range gets applied.
So we still have a lot
of dynamic range.
We're not wasting the
dynamic range.
But it helps us to
avoid clipping.
The second thing here
is I've been passing
these time values around.
Like here I call
audioContext.currentTime plus 600.
So time, in the Web Audio API,
is an interesting beast
because it's in seconds.
It's not in milliseconds.
But it's a floating-point
number.
And this is really why we used
milliseconds for a long time.
I imagine that very few of you
in the room have not used
setTimeout at one point or
another in web programming.
SetTimeout takes values
in milliseconds.
The problem with this is a
millisecond is actually a
really long time when
you're looking at
each sample of audio.
Right?
In one millisecond, on a
CD-quality audio, that's 44
and a tenth samples.
You're not very precise
in that case.
So we needed something more
precise and went with seconds
not milliseconds.
Secondly, you want to
grab this from the
audioContext.currentTime.
You don't grab it
from time.now or
something like that.
It's not the Unix Epoch clock.
It actually starts at zero when
the context is created.
That's not a super useful point
in time, it's more a
relative unit than an absolute
unit, in that sense.
But finally, and also critically
important, you kind
of have to be careful.
Because this is a
different clock.
It literally may have a
different clock crystal that
it's running off of.
Because audio hardware systems
frequently have a separate
crystal that keeps the
audio very stable.
And the CPU may spin its
crystal up or down or
something like that for power
management reasons.
So by now, we're, I don't know,
a little under halfway
through, and you're thinking,
that's great.
You dumped a bunch of types on
me, a whole bunch of code, and
fundamentally all you did
was make a dog bark.
And I can loop that in the
HTML5 audio tag, too.
So what have you shown me that's
really interesting?
Well, first and foremost, you
don't usually do code the way
that I did it there.
Most particularly, you don't
usually immediately play the
sound buffer when you've loaded
it with web audio.
It's called a buffer
for a reason.
You want to keep it around
for a while.
In fact, I use about a dozen
sound samples during the
course of this talk.
And I've loaded all of them.
I loaded them all when the page
loaded the first time.
And I just hang on
to the buffer.
And I use them whenever
I want.
So there are a couple samples
that I use repeatedly.
They're already in memory.
I don't need to worry about,
Are they still there?
Do I load them again?
Are they going to get
cached or not?
Now, there is, of course,
one other
critical difference here.
Which is the Web Audio API has
a lot of audio nodes for
processing.
We can do a lot of interesting
things with the audio, once
we've started playing.
I just wanted to get
out of the way,
how do you play something.
Because it's actually
relatively easy.
And by the way, if you want to
use the HTML5 audio, as I did
mention before, HTML5 audio
supports streaming.
And streaming is a critically
important thing to do for some
types of audio.
If you want to play background
music for a game, for example,
you may not want to load
all of that into
an in-memory buffer.
So here, you can take an HTML5
audio element and grab its
audio output by calling
audioContext.cre
ateMediaElementSource, handing
it the HTML5 audio or video
element, and it grabs the sound
output from that tag,
from that element.
And then you can connect it
to wherever you want.
You can connect it to the
effects pipeline.
You can route it.
You can change its gain,
all kinds of things.
So it does integrate very
well into the Web
Audio API as well.
So I want to walk through each
of the types of processing
nodes, and what they can do,
and how to use them.
The first one, and kind of the
easiest one to knock out
first, I guess, is
the gain node.
And gain node is pretty
straightforward.
It lets you control the
gain, AKA volume.
And I'll just drop a sound file
in, drop a gain node in,
connect the sound file to the
gain node, the speakers.
Let's choose a different
sound here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS WILSON: OK.
So I've done my sound playing.
And now I can change
the gain value.
[MUSIC FADES OUT]
CHRIS WILSON: And it
makes it quieter.
[MUSIC FADES IN]
CHRIS WILSON: Or makes
it a lot louder.
Pretty straightforward,
pretty easy.
However, it's important to
understand gain nodes are
fantastically useful and really,
really important.
Because this is how you create
a lot of the points in the
routing graph.
This is how you create things
like sub-mixes.
If you are implementing a game
sound manager, for example,
and you're creating a bunch of
effect sounds, like guns
firing, or whatever, that
probably all gets connected to
a single gain node
that lets you
control the effects volume.
And then you have a different
gain node that lets you
control the music volume.
And maybe you have a master
volume that they
both connect to.
But all of these
routing points,
frequently, are gain nodes.
Because they're an easy
thing to hang off of.
I should also mention, by the
way, implicitly you can make
more than one connection at
any node connection point.
If you connect multiple nodes to
one destination, they just
automatically mix together.
So if I have my dog barking--
[BARK]
CHRIS
WILSON: --my cat [MEOW]
CHRIS WILSON: --and I just
connect them both to the same
destination down below,
and call noteOn
on at the same time--
[SIMULTANEOUS BARK AND MEOW]
CHRIS WILSON: You get
them both together.
It just mixes them together.
And, of course, if I connected
one node to multiple
destination nodes,
that also works.
It just automatically
fans out.
In fact, my vocoder app in the
beginning, I mentioned at one
point it's a 28-band vocoder.
That means one of the nodes fans
out to 28 other nodes.
And then at the other end, 28
nodes all have to mix back
down together into one node.
And I just do that by
connecting them.
I didn't have to do anything
special or come up with a
special node to do that.
Now, I also want to point out--
remember I said that all
the things that you would think
of like parameters, like
gain on a gain node, are
actually AudioParams.
This lets you do automation.
So I can do things like
this automated fade
that I played earlier.
[MUSIC FADES IN AND OUT]
CHRIS WILSON: I should
have played earlier.
And it fades it in,
and fades it out.
And I did this simply by saying,
I want to start by
creating a gain node, inserting
it into the path,
and then, right now, set
the value to zero.
In two seconds, I want you
to have ramped up to 1.0.
And four seconds from now, I
want you to have ramped back
down to zero.
These are really
easy to set up.
And as I said, they happen
very, very smoothly.
Because we handle them under
the covers a very high time
resolution.
Now my next node type--
it's also relatively basic--
is a delay node.
Now, it's pretty obvious
what a delay node does.
It delays the audio
sent through it.
So I'm going to create a delay
node and hook it up.
And I'll hit play--
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: --and the
interesting thing is you
probably didn't notice
anything different.
Well, it's because what
goes through the
node is entirely delayed.
So it's not mixing it
back together with
the original sound.
It's only delaying all the
audio going through it.
So there was an extra 0.2
seconds from when I hit the
button to when it played.
But of course that's not
really noticeable.
Now, if I wanted to, to sound
like an echo, then I can
connect the original source
straight to the speaker
destination, too, and
play it again.
And now you get the
echo effect.
Now if you really want what you
classically think of as a
fading feedback echo digital
delay, you want to
add a gain node in.
Let's move it where we
can actually see
where the routing goes.
And you want to put a cycle
through this delay.
So the output of the delay
goes into the gain node.
And the gain node goes
back into the delay.
And a critically important
piece is set the
gain less than one.
And now when I play it, it's
gonna cycle through this
delay-gain, delay-gain,
delay-gain, until the sound
just dies back down to zero.
So you can hear how I can
build a digital delay.
In fact, for any studio
engineer types in the
audience, if you want to build
multi-tap delays, you just
stack a few delay nodes
in parallel.
If you want to do things like
multi-channel effects like
ping-pong delay, I'll actually
get into that later.
They're really easy to do.
Because you have the basic
tool kit for doing delay.
And all you have to
do is route it in
an interesting way.
Now another amazing thing is
that delay time is actually an
audio param.
That means you can schedule
changes to it.
You can make changes to it live
and things will happen.
So if I wanted to do code like
this, I can actually increase
the delay time over time.
And it automatically
makes it happen.
So--
PLAYBACK: [ECHOING]
Hello.
CHRIS WILSON: OK.
That one didn't sound right.
I'm gonna restart this.
For some reason, this
demo occasionally
decides to be finicky.
So I'm gonna try
that one again.
PLAYBACK: [ECHOING]
Hello.
CHRIS WILSON: There we go.
Kind of a subtle effect.
But it's basically increasing
the delay time over time.
I mentioned before, you can also
connect audio nodes into
AudioParams, like take the
output of an audio feed and
pump it straight in as a
parameter controller.
This is how you do effects like
flanging and chorusing,
which basically just have an
oscillator modulating the
display time.
I'll have a demo about that
up on the net later.
I didn't put it in here because
it's kind of hard to
walk through the code for it.
Now is the time, actually, in
this talk, to introduce a
really, really good
friend of mine--
the RealtimeAnalyserNode.
And I say a really, really good
friend of mine because I
used these constantly while
I was debugging my vocoder
application to figure out
what was going on
in the sound feed.
Because it turns out, you really
cannot debug an audio
application by using
console.log to
spit out sound values.
It just doesn't work.
Like you have 44,000 values blow
past in a second, you're
not going to recognize the
pattern and say, Oh yeah,
that's a sine wave.
So the RealtimeAnalyserNode
is what lets
you visualize things.
Like this.
So all that this does--
you can set this up and tell
it, I want to get an array
that represents the frequency
band energy.
And you can tell it how
detailed you want
that array to be.
Or you can say, I want kind
of a chunk of the
waveform, as well.
We use the same node to give
you both of those features.
The frequency data you can ask
for as a Unit8 or as a float.
It's kind of totally up to
you in your coding how
you want to do it.
So let's see how we
actually do this.
So here's how you use it.
The frequency buckets, by the
way, are split up linearly
across zero to the NyQuist
frequency, which is half of
the AudioContext's
sample rate.
So if you say you want 1,024
buckets, then it's going to
chop that up evenly
across zero to
probably 22.05 kilohertz.
And then, at some point in time,
what you do is you go to
your analyser.
And you pass it an array
that you've created.
And you say, Give me the bite
frequency count data here.
And it performs the frequency
analysis of the current sound
and passes it back to you.
And then of course you just go
in a loop through that array.
Do whatever you want to make
something interesting
visually, or do interesting
analysis, or
whatever you want.
In the case of this visualizer,
all I did was I
walked through that array
and drew little
boxes on the screen.
But, of course, if you do that
on a RequestAnimationFrame
timer, then it happens at the
refresh rate of your monitor
or whatever.
And you can do something
that looks very live.
Right.
You're doing it constantly.
You're getting lots
of analysis.
Please, by the way, don't use
setTimeout to do this.
SetTimeout's not a great way
to do animation anyways.
But it gets even worse
in sound sometimes.
So now that we've looked
at frequency analysers.
Now we can talk about
filter nodes.
So filtering is a process
that happens in
the frequency domain.
It changes the response
across frequencies.
So we have a bunch of
different types.
We have LOWPASS, HIGHPASS,
BANDPASS, LOW and HIGH
shelving filters, PEAKING
filter, NOTCH filter, and
ALLPASS filter.
I don't expect to magically
know what all
those do, or care.
This actually let you play with
the parameters and see
what happens when you change
the frequency.
When you change from a LOWPASS
filter, which lets all the low
frequencies through but cuts
off the high ones, to a
HIGHPASS filter, you can
see how it shifts.
It's a neat little graph to play
with and gives you some
idea of how things work.
And, by the way, the parameters
in this are
frequency and Q, or occasionally
what's referred
to as quality, or sometimes
resonance.
Because it's sort of
a related concept.
So like here, if I pump up the
Q, you can see how it sort of
accentuates whatever
the frequency is.
It's causing a resonance
right at that spot.
Now this is great.
I'm showing you some
neat graphs.
You can actually hear and see
how it sounds, by using my
neat little demo app here.
And don't worry, this is the
most complex graph I'm going
to draw in this thing on my
little track-pad here.
So let's create an
AudioBufferSource, grab an
analyser, a filter, and
another analyser.
And let's see if I can get these
all to fit on the screen
at the same time.
There we go.
Connect.
You know, If I had had time I
would have figured out how to
pre-load these in
my app, but--
all right.
Let's use our same drum
sample and loop it.
[MUTED DRUMS]
CHRIS WILSON: And you can hear
how all the high frequencies
are getting cut off on
this sound sample.
You can actually see it in the
difference between the before
and after analyser here.
And if I play with
the frequency--
[MUSIC FADES IN]
CHRIS WILSON: --you can
hear it open up.
And now I'm pretty much passing
through all of the
frequencies.
But just for kicks, let's
crank up the resonance.
[MUSIC WARPS]
CHRIS WILSON: OK.
So I'm not Paul Oakenfold.
But you get how this
stuff works.
And you get the application
of these kinds of things.
Now it's turning into
a UI problem--
to build some really cool DJ
tools, which I'm kind of
excited about building next.
That'll be my next
little fun game.
Now, I also wanted to point out,
again, frequency and Q?
They're both AudioParams, so
you can automate them.
You can change these
automatically over time.
And so I took this, and I took
the output of a standard, I
think it's a triangle wave, and
just pumped it straight
into a filter.
So the original sound is
an unchanging wave.
And I just changed the filter
and told it, hey, sweep the
filter from zero to 2,000 hertz
over the course of two
seconds, and then back
down to zero.
I think I automated
the Q, too.
[SOUND EFFECT]
CHRIS WILSON: So you can do
these neat little filter
sweeps really, really easily.
That actually is the
code snippet pasted
out of my js file.
And you can take that same
filter, and you can use it to
process other things.
You don't have to have an
unchanging sound that you
start with.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
CHRIS WILSON: Sorry, I should
have cranked that up a little.
[MUSIC PLAYS LOUDER]
CHRIS WILSON: So you can do
all kinds of fun things by
automating those filters, as
well as just twiddling the
values yourself.
In fact, filters are also how
you get effects like, I'm
talking on a telephone, or I'm
talking on an am radio, or
something like that.
You can take the original
sound, here--
PLAYBACK: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: Which
you heard earlier.
And all that I do in this other
sample is I pump it
through a couple of filters to
mask off the low and the high
frequencies.
It turns out a telephone sound
is really just-- the old
telephone system chopped off
all of the upper and lower
frequencies.
Because of the way that
they transferred the
data across the lines.
PLAYBACK: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: And you get
something like that, just by
filtering off those
frequencies.
CHRIS WILSON: So now we've got
all these really cool sounds,
or the tools to build all of
them, we need to position them
in 3D space.
There's a great tutorial on
HTML5Rocks about this.
I basically decided I couldn't
improve on that a whole lot,
so I was just going to show
the demo for it--
[MUSIC PLAYS]
CHRIS WILSON: And talk through
it a little bit.
And you'll see as we
move around here--
hopefully, you're hearing
the audio move around.
I wanna thank the sound guys
again for getting the room set
up for stereo.
Because it definitely
would not been
as impressive otherwise.
So the way that you do this is
you create an AudioPannerNode.
You just pump your sound into
an AudioPannerNode.
And you set its position, its
orientation if you want to
sound to be directional,
and its velocity.
And this sounds really
complex to do.
Obviously, it makes sense for
the demo that I just showed
you where it's really
a 3D space.
But maybe you just want to take
a normal sound and pan it
to the left or the right.
Well that's actually
really easy to do.
You just create a panner node,
you set the position to
straight ahead, and then you can
animate the x position to
change where it is,
left or right.
And you end up with something
like this--
[MUSIC PLAYS, PANNING
LEFT AND RIGHT]
CHRIS WILSON: So it's actually
really easy to do simple
things, as well.
You don't have to do super
complex 3D math to figure out
where to position things.
This is also, by the way, how
you get Doppler effects.
That whole setVelocity
method is to set the
velocity of an object.
So that you get these
sounds where--
[SIREN]
CHRIS WILSON: You can hear the
pitch change as something
races past you.
So given the number of
ambulances or policemen that
I've heard going around on the
streets of San Francisco the
last couple days, you
hear this a lot.
But you expect that
sound to change.
If you were playing a game and
you raced past the police
officer in the game and the
pitch of the siren didn't
change, you would
actually notice.
It would be kind of weird.
It would be jarring.
Because that's not the way that
it works in real life.
And this just magically
happened.
All you had to do was set the
velocity of the object and we
knew to change the pitch
of the object.
Now, all of these things.
All of these AudioPannerNodes
that may be in play, they're
all relative to a listener
somewhere.
You have to position
the person hearing
all of these things.
And the person hearing all these
things is an attribute
of the speakers, in effect.
It's an attribute of
the entire context.
So the AudioListener hangs
directly off the AudioContext.
There's only one of them.
You don't create these.
It's always there.
And you just set your position,
or your orientation
or velocity.
When I moved around in that
sound field during the demo a
couple seconds ago, I was
changing the AudioListener
properties, as well as the
visual representation of that.
So with that, I want to jump
to another fun node--
the ConvolverNode.
So convolution is a process to
digitally simulate a space, or
a process actually.
Because you can use this to
simulate room ambiance, like
the way sound bounces
around in this room.
This room has kind of a
nice response to it.
I can hear my voice bouncing
off the back wall.
But you can also use it to
simulate an analog processor.
Something that you use to plug
an audio signal through.
The way that this works is you
use these things called
Impulse Response files.
And Impulse Response files
can be recorded.
You can literally go into a room
like this with a couple
microphones and a speaker, play
a set of sounds, and then
run that through this
convolution processing
software, and it creates
a sound file that is
representative of how this room
responds to a sound impulse.
Or you can have been generated
algorithmically.
Or you can just come up with
really wacky ones, which
usually has very unpredictable
results, of course.
But fundamentally, in order to
simulate different responses,
you have to use this
file, a sound file.
There are tons of these
available on the net, freely.
You can just go search for
Impulse Response files.
Tons of them are out there.
Lots of hall reverbs, room
reverbs, and things like that,
as well as some really
crazy ones.
Again, I do want to point out
the output of this node is
just the processed signal.
And typically, you don't
just hear the echos.
You hear the original
sound too.
So you probably want to mix
these together when you
actually use it.
But ConvolverNode is pretty
straightforward because it
basically has one property that
you really care about.
It's a buffer.
Remember I said these are
Impulse Response files.
They're sound files.
You load them the same way you
load any other sound sample.
You just set it here, rather
than setting it in
AudioBufferSource node.
So to do this, I'm going to use
my favorite drum sample
that I keep using.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
CHRIS WILSON: Turn that
down a little bit.
And so I took my drum sound, I
created a ConvolverNode, I
pumped the drum sound into that
ConvolverNode, but also
connected it to the speakers--
to the destination.
So I hear both of them.
And then all that I'm going to
do now, is I'm gonna switch
what the ImpulseResponseBuffer
is.
So I can change it to a hall--
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: Which I
hope you can hear.
I can change it to
a spring reverb.
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: Spring reverb is
an old analog processor that
literally used springs.
And you can kind of hear this
weird slapping noise going
back and forth as a
characteristic of spring reverb.
You can do a comb filter.
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: Which has a
really, really awful sound.
I'm not gonna stay
on that one.
Or, my personal favorite with
drums, is a backwards reverb.
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: Because you can
do any Impulse Response.
This Impulse Response may be
completely the opposite in
time of what you would
actually hear
in the reverb space.
So if I stop it.
[MUSIC FADES]
CHRIS WILSON: You can actually
hear the reversed
reverb sound of that.
OK.
So we've talked a lot
about how to build
these processing systems.
I want to talk for a minute
about how to synthesize sound.
How to do musical applications
with sound, not just provide
ambient environments
for sound.
First and foremost,
it's actually
really easy to do this.
If you go and just do a search
for Web Audio API demos,
there's a whole bunch of demos
out there that are different
synthesizers.
This is only one of them.
It's actually a fairly
simplistic one,
which is why use it.
But--
[PLAYS SYNTHESIZER]
CHRIS WILSON: It has controls
for all of these different
things that I'm playing
around with.
It's actually--
the hardest part about building
something like this
is providing the user
experience for it.
I've actually built a test-bed
synthesizer out that
has no UI at all.
And it's really easy-- like the
actual sound production.
I want to build an envelope, I
want to stick a filter in, I
want to control some other
properties of it, is like a
dozen lines of code.
The rest of it, the shell for
drawing knobs and everything
else is actually a lot
more troublesome.
And remember when I mentioned
before, you can actually
connect AudioNodes to
AudioParams, as well.
For those of you who are synth
geeks, like me-- because I've
loved synthesizers since
I was about 12--
this is how you get things
like low-frequency
oscillators.
It's how you do things
like FM synthesis.
They're actually just
intersecting two different
audio signals or multiplying
them together.
So the first and most
fundamental piece of
generating sound is
an oscillator.
Oscillators provide a periodic
waveform source.
It's going to draw for you, or
create for you, things like a
sine
wave, [BEEP]
CHRIS WILSON: Square wave.
[BEEP]
CHRIS WILSON: Sawtooth wave.
CHRIS WILSON: And
a triangle wave.
[BEEP]
CHRIS WILSON: Those all sound
kind of vaguely similar.
It's because I didn't
alter the pitch.
I haven't filtered them.
They're not super complex
waveforms.
But they are different.
And they have very different
harmonic characteristics,
which give you some interesting
properties.
So an oscillator is an
AudioSourceNode.
It's an audio node that you
can connect up to a
destination.
It lets you control the
frequency in hertz, it
actually also lets you
control the frequency
with the detune parameter.
Detuning basically lets you
control using a different unit
known as cents.
Cents are great for musical
applications because in an
equal-tempered scale there's
100 cents per note.
So it's super easy to say,
I want three octaves up.
It's three times 12 times 100.
And just like
AudioBufferSourceNode you have
noteOn, noteOff, and that
sort of things.
Now, I did skip that we
have another type up
there, called custom.
Custom lets us use this really
interesting oscillator called
a wavetable oscillator.
Wavetables are not a sample
playback buffer.
The term got misused in
the late '80s and
early '90s for a while.
It's actually a way to produce
sound that uses--
looks like my page didn't
load, hang on.
Let's try this again.
There we go.
It creates wave forms by adding
different coefficients
onto harmonic partials.
So it basically stacks up
harmonics of the same tone.
And then lets you control how
much of each harmonic to draw,
or to play, to add
to the waveform.
So here, we start out
with a fairly
simple set of harmonics.
[DEEP BUZZING NOISE]
CHRIS WILSON: There's three
harmonics playing.
And it sounds pretty basic.
It's not a very rich
sound or anything.
But I can draw in more--
[SOUND ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: And you can get a
lot more interesting sound.
So this is kind of weird.
It's a very deep area to build
complex waveforms.
Because you can sit there
and tweak the
partials all you want.
But I don't want to go
too deeply into it.
Because we could just sit
here and play with
partials all day.
It's a different way
of creating sounds.
It's a different generation
system.
It actually was very popular
in the early '80s.
There was a PPG wave synthesizer
that kind of
kicked off the usage of this.
The great thing, to me,
is this creates a very
spectrum-rich sound, creates a
lot of harmonics, which was
super useful in building
the vocoder.
The sound that I used
for that vocoder
is actually a wavetable.
OK.
So we've created sound.
Now we need to process
it a little bit more.
And there a couple of node
types that are really
musically interesting.
The first of these is
Compressor node.
Now compressors are a very
common musical tool.
In fact, that picture of a
rack of music equipment?
That's actually from
my basement studio.
One of the units in that is
a hardware compressor.
And compression basically
controls the volume peaks of a
sound, but tries to increase
the overall volume.
So this is a before-and-after
picture of the same sound
sample, of me playing
my bass guitar.
The first one is uncompressed.
The second one is compressed.
I've actually increased the
average volume, but I've had
to turn it down in a couple of
places to make sure that I
don't spike past the
clipping range.
So this is kind of like having
an engineer who sits there
with his hand on the volume knob
with an extremely fast
reaction time.
You can actually see
how this works--
[MUSIC PLAYS]
CHRIS WILSON: Here.
These are really standardized
controls, by the way.
The AudioParams that give you
controls on Compressor node
for threshold, knee, ratio,
attack, and release.
These are the five standard
things that you get on a
compressor.
There's actually knobs that say
threshold, knee, ratio,
attack, and release
on that hardware
compressor that I have.
[MUSIC VOLUME INCREASES]
CHRIS WILSON: Now the little
bouncing red bar shows you how
much compression is being
applied at any
given point in time.
So I can crank the threshold
down, crank the knee up, crank
the ratio up.
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: And you can
probably tell in the back.
It sounds a little
muddled, for me.
But you can probably
tell in the back.
Suddenly, the peaks aren't so
loud, but the whole sound is a
little bit muddled right
now, actually.
Because you don't generally
over-compress like this.
If you want to, you can change
the attack time, and you'll
start hearing some of the--
[MUSIC ALTERS]
CHRIS WILSON: Some of the
poppiness of the attack is
back, which is why you have all
these different controls.
[MUSIC STOPS]
CHRIS WILSON: So I'm not going
to do a class in how to use
compressors.
I just wanted to say, this
is a tool that we have.
The last processing node
tool in our toolbox is
a WaveShaper node.
WaveShapers are a little
bit complex to explain.
Basically, what they do is they
let you create a curve, a
response curve, that's like
a sample look-up table.
And it happens on every
sound sample.
So for every sample it
says, I'm actually
going to return this.
If I set a curve that was
actually just a flat line on a
45 degree angle down here, then
it would actually just
have the output be exactly
the same as the input.
Otherwise it's going to change
the waveforms that go through.
Not control the volume over
time, like a Compressor node.
But actually change the
waveforms and kind of squish
the peaks down a little bit.
So I can use this to create like
distortion and overdrive.
[GUITAR]
CHRIS WILSON: So here, you have
me playing the guitar.
And if I just drive the gain a
little bit more to push up
into the areas that
get clipped off--
[GUITAR DISTORTS]
CHRIS WILSON: You can hear
it sounds like a guitar
distortion pedal, or
over-driving an amplifier.
And this is just a--
[GUITAR STOPS]
CHRIS WILSON: A single sound
curve that I created and
shoved into there.
You can actually change these
curves infinitely.
You can give it any size of
array curve that you want.
And you can change what the
response looks like and get
very, very different
distortion effects.
OK.
Almost there.
So I haven't mentioned mono
sound versus stereo sound,
versus 5.1 surround sound,
or anything like that.
Mostly because the Web Audio
API, for the most part, just
kind of handles it for you.
You don't have to deal
with channels.
It just sort of magically
upgrades whenever it needs to
go to stereo, or if you have a
mono signal, or upgrades all
the way to 5.1 surround sound
if it has to, whatever.
If you really do want
to poke into channel
control, you can do that.
Most of those connections may
be more than one channel.
And you just don't have to worry
about whether it's a
mono or stereo signal.
If you want to, use an audio
channel splitter and an audio
channel merger.
So for example, I mentioned
a ping-pong delay.
Ping-pong delay bounces the
delay back and forth between
the left and the
right channels.
So it sounds kind
of like this--
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: Hopefully you hear
that bouncing between the
channels back there.
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: You'd accomplish
this just by taking two
delays, feeding the original
signal into one side,
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: And then crossing
the feedback loop.
So it goes from the left channel
output into the right
channel's delay node and
then back the same
way the other direction.
And, of course, you can
individually control in here
how long the delay is for each
side, and that kind of stuff.
So I mentioned at the very
beginning you can actually
plug in and do any kind of
custom JavaScript you want to,
on a sound node.
JavaScriptAudioNode is
how you do that.
You plug in, you set up an event
listener, and then you
process buffers of audio
in that event listener.
I'm not going to go into
the demo of this.
It's really subtle and it takes
a lot of explaining.
And we are at about three
minutes left, I think.
So but this is how you do it.
There's some pretty good
examples of how to do it on
the Chromium sight.
And I want to jump to where
we are with Web Audio.
One of the first questions
is always, So
is this Chrome only?
And it is supported in Chrome,
Windows, Mac OS, and Linux.
ChromeOS actually just
enabled it, as well.
So we have it on Chrome OS.
But even more interestingly,
Safari has now enabled in
nightly builds and
it's shipping in
the Safari 5.2 beta.
And, my personal favorite,
it's now on the
iOS 6 betas, also.
So you can get the Web Audio
API on your iPhone or iPad.
Apple actually covered the Web
Audio API in one of their
sessions in WWDC earlier
this month, which
I thought was great.
And we have some really active
discussion going on on the Web
Audio working group, of
which I'm a member.
We have a bunch of active
participants from Mozilla,
Opera, the Internet Explorer
team, a bunch of other
industry people, as well,
helping to get the
specification to the point where
we can get rid of vendor
prefix and turn it into
a solid standard.
And, of course, if you need
it today though in other
browsers, use ChromeFrame.
I promised I would plug
for ChromeFrame, so.
So we are just about
out of time.
But I did want to call out two
features that I'm actually
really excited about coming
up in the future.
They're not quite there yet, so
I can't demo them, really.
But they are exciting.
And I also want to kind of
paint a picture of what I
really hope people build
and what I'm really
excited about building.
First and foremost, I'm super
pumped to have audio input.
Jan can tell you I keep pinging
the team like, When am
I gonna get my audio input?
When am I going to get
my audio input?
Mostly because I want
to plug a live
microphone into my vocoder.
And do stuff like that, like
plug my guitar in and create
my own guitar amp simulators,
and stuff like that.
Because they're pretty easy to
do using the Web Audio API.
Not quite there yet, hopefully
will be in the near future.
The second one is one that is
a little bit further out.
But I'm actually the co-editor
of a proposal in the W3C to do
MIDI input.
Some of you up front may notice
that I've actually
driven some of these demos off
a little keyboard here.
I'm cheating because
that uses a plugin.
And I've just hard-wired the
plug-in in to do the
appropriate thing.
But the specification that I'm
co-editing will eventually
allow us to have that as part
of the web platform.
And we can natively just
handle MIDI input.
So you can do controllers,
you can access external
synthesizers, you can do all
kinds of cool stuff.
Light shows are generally driven
by MIDI, as well, like
all the controllers for the
fancy lights last night are
driven through that.
Now for awesome apps
that I really want
to see people build?
There's tons of them.
First and foremost, great game
audio, like really richly
interactive.
Don't just make it beep.
Make it beep differently
depending on some parameter I
can't even think of.
Like how fast someone's
running, or whatever.
But we have the tools to build
shared music composition
tools, and digital audio
workstations, and all this
kind of stuff today.
So with that, no deck is
complete without tons of
references.
You don't have to
memorize these
because the deck's posted.
You don't even have to memorize
the thing at the top,
because it's on my last slide in
a shortened form and it'll
be easier to read.
If you don't already follow
Chrome developers on Google+,
please add us to a circle.
We do lots of communication
there.
But we do try to keep it nice
and concise and useful and
interesting.
And with that, thank you.
We're basically out of time.
But I'm going to
be around now.
I'll be outside once we've
packed up here.
And I'll be doing office hours
for the next hour or two, too,
if you have other questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]